every day is take your dog to work day
for Lucia good dog Lucy awara gross is a
career the next job pops up on her
smartphone and off she goes to downtown
San Francisco she uses her own car to
deliver restaurant meals or grocery
shopping to customers but Lucy is not
permanently employed she's an
independent businesswoman this ice is
for a company party and she's in a hurry
not just because it'll melt but because
she gets a flat rate per delivery her
orders come via delivery company post
mates who say their couriers can earn up
to $25 an hour I make between six
dollars and ten dollars an hour so in
San Francisco where the minimum wage is
1250 I make less than the minimum wage
she needs to get a five-star review from
every customer and she finds the
pressure stressful if you have a 4.7 or
less you can't do the job
yeah the customers also decide how much
she earns she lives off tips because the
money from post mates only covers the
cost of her car I have to pay for gas
it's about twenty dollars a day I have
to pay for car insurance it's a hundred
dollars a month and I have a car payment
which is about two hundred and sixty
eight dollars a month Bill Hanson is
taking on the other end of the street
he's been working as a courier for post
mates for three months he likes the
independence and only works at lucrative
times a day it's a second job for him
but today is full of problems this
address is a building site there's no
one here to take the delivery the fee is
calculated on delivery distance so as I
just learned on earlier job today if it
takes me two hours used to only get six
bucks so this I have no idea what it
would be but then if they don't respond
and they canceled the order then I have
to email the city manager to get paid I
won't automatically get paid I have to
ask for it
he never knows what's coming and he's
not allowed to turn down orders even
though they've given you a job that you
weren't even aware was going to be this
low-paying time-consuming job if you ask
for a reassigned they still reserve the
right to suspend you from the platform
it's totally set up in their favor and
completely not fair post mates is a
growing company and is already active in
26 US cities with an army of courier
drivers but because they're not
permanently employed the company doesn't
cover extra costs like insurance and for
every order twenty percent goes straight
into post mates pockets when asked for
an interview nobody was available to
comment delivery services like these
have seen a boom in rich cities like San
Francisco and they create jobs for
thousands of new independent suppliers
Bill Hanson doesn't live solely from his
career job but he says many others have
to
if you're requiring three or four
different platforms or three or four
different companies to make it a livable
wage if that becomes the new standard by
which we create business models that's
actually the part that concerns me about
this stuff but some what's the bad about
it I don't know do you wake up every
morning wanting to have three jobs I
don't think anyone does after five hours
and four orders Lucia leaves san
francisco she lives in a small town
outside the city man she's training to
be a social worker but does she see a
future with post mates way why would I
why would I stay with those maids
I would have a proper job it just
doesn't make sense bleak prospects for
Jimmy the dog if Lucia gets a proper job
he might be stuck home alone